have learned that to grow as an
executive and to have a wider impact on
the company I need to make sure the
broader team around me is successful
that is one thing Insight that I've had
over the past few years welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside fam Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this is an episode all about engineering
leadership with mad of Nair senior vice
president of engineering at Zoom info a
leading go to market intelligence
platform designed to drive a Brand's
sales marketing and recruiting
initiatives seamlessly and profitably in
his role model is responsible for
leading engineering for all applications
and data services development quality
and delivery of zoominfo's software
products
[Music]
talking about
engineering leadership
obviously yeah just reading out your
background you know is so so crazy and
impressive and I'm sure that if we were
to go through each of your experiences
there would be a multitude of stories
for you to share things you've learned
what I really want to unpack with you
over these 20 minutes is growing as an
engineering leader and how you've
progressed over the years to become you
know the leader that you are today what
are some things that you've realized
about engineering leadership or things
that you got excited by
um in this space both from a
technological perspective but also from
a managerial perspective and so we'll
have it we'll definitely have a great
time in these 20 minutes so thank you
again for being here and I'll start off
you know with
just looking back tell me a little bit
about how you are in this space you know
mod of probably you know what is the
trajectory that you set out for yourself
as you enter this engineering world
sure when I started my career like most
of us in this space as an engineer I was
in development I enjoyed doing
development and I was happy going back
until one day maybe 20 plus years ago
when my manager at that time asked me to
interview a few candidates and I I
remember going back terrified to my wife
asking her what should I ask this
candidates what does this mean why am I
interviewing people but looking back
that was the start of the journey when I
started uh learning how to how to grow a
team manage a team and and uh you know
expand my rules on there so that was
pretty much the start I did continue
doing development and coding for a while
along with managing people but after a
while it became uh that evolved into
more of uh Morris Engineering Management
where I grew my trajectory from being a
manager into a senior manager director
vice president senior vice president and
so on so uh even though I I still tackle
in technology encode I I do not write
code myself right now but I believe I'm
adding value in a ton of other areas
how has your thinking around
Tech evolved or engineering evolved over
the years and position yourself from
from developer to to an executive how is
your relationship with engineering
changed sure I don't know if it's
specific to engineering but I believe
one of the foundational principles that
I believe in is as you grow up the Earth
uh the career ladder so to speak and
start interacting with a diverse crew
you realize that your accountability is
not just around delivering for your
immediate team that you manage it's
about delivering for the bigger team
um if you are familiar with the Patrick
lemsion is Works he talks about the five
dysfunctions of a team he talks about
the notion of which is Europe first team
and what that means to me is the my
first team is honestly my manager's team
right the CTO staff which I'm part of so
my success as an engineering leader
right now I would attribute to make
taking the CTO staff successful and not
just about my engineering organization
and that realization happens pretty late
I realized that quite late into my
career that up to a point was focused on
making my team outrageously successful
which I still need to do but I've
learned that to grow as an executive and
to have a wider impact on the company I
need to make sure the broader team
around me is successful that is one
thing Insight that I've had over the
past few years
awesome
passion and excitement and we have the
privilege of working and on problems and
Fields that were that we truly are
excited about so I generally leave this
in question to the end but I think that
this is something that I want to to come
back to in this in this episode so
tell me a little bit about your own
passion and excitement in the in the
field that you're that you're in there
are two things one related to technology
and product and the other relate to
people maybe uh start off with the
product and Technology but I'm
fascinated and passionate about
companies in this space where you're no
longer a startup you're kind of evolves
from being a startup at the same time
you're no longer I mean you're not yet
uh thirty thousand fifty thousand people
organization right so I am fascinated by
that in between Space by which how you
can scale up a company visited really
well as a startup and do this bigger
enterprise-wide organization what does
that really mean it means that you need
to scale in terms of your technology
stack you need to scale in terms of your
processes the the scaffolding that you
put in place right so what's really got
you to your first 100 million dollars to
use the cliche isn't what we're told get
you to your one billion dollars right so
so that is something I'm really
passionate about I enjoy working in that
space where it's all all about scale
technology skill people scale process
scale and so on right so that's like one
thing I'm extremely passionate about the
other which is more personal to me and
more also people oriented area is around
diversity equity and inclusion I do
believe and Studies have shown that uh
organizations which have a diverse
Workforce redeliver much more Innovative
durable and richer solutions to problems
as compared to organizational groups
that have that are homogeneous right so
at any organization I've been in
especially the past 10 to 15 years I've
tried to make a difference in ensuring
that there is attention to diversity
Equity intrusion and we have a sadly
robust heterogeneous Workforce coming
from diverse backgrounds and I've seen
myself that the solution that each of
those groups provide whether it's
technology or or on the product or
design right becomes much more Rich so
that's another area which I'm quite
passionate about
very very cool and if you had to sort of
put it put yourself you know at not not
thirty thousand feet let's say 100 feet
and you're now examining your own
relationship with with the people you
work with from a leadership perspective
and uh and you look today at the way
that you're looking at your leadership
style what what Would You observe how
does this interaction take place what
have you noticed to be most effective in
being a a good leader for for the people
that you're working with so I'd like to
lead with empathy
um what that means is uh being an active
listener understanding where people come
from when they say something is really
important to me right especially when
you're leading and managing a Workforce
that is distributed across the globe I
have we have teams in in the US in
Canada uh fairly big team in Israel
um a fast growing team out of India
right and and appreciating that people
come from different cultures and
backgrounds and how they communicate may
be distant from the way I've been used
to communicating right so when you go at
that level I really uh I really try to
establish MacBook
find the firm foundational relationship
between the individual lands and working
with the talking to and that helps me a
lot in all my interactions and and this
across functions not just in engineering
if I'm meeting with say folks from sales
or marketing or Finance right I try to
get that level of some apple and that
relationship going which I believe has
really uh helped me and I believe will
help everyone
yeah I I like that so let's dive a
little bit into Zoom info and what
you're doing today as a company and what
you're doing especially from an
engineering standpoint so share with me
a little bit about some info from your
from your lenses I'm sure a lot of
people listening already no Zoom info
it's a company that I personally uh am
inspired by very much but would love to
hear from your lips sure yeah we think
of ourselves as the go to market
platform right so zoom in for software
enables uh business to business sales
marketing and recruiting professionals
to sign reach out and uh convert Target
companies and Prospects with our uh
pretty much Android those data
governance accuracy and depth of context
so we provide the data the tools the
insights uh that the sales and the
marketing and recruiting professional
needs to kind of close their next big
deal uh we provide engagement platforms
on top of that it's essentially a go to
market platform and I joined the company
two years ago almost of the day it was
in October 2020 that I joined
um and at that time my team the
applications engineering team was about
150 people
um and over the past two years we've
just increased by Leaps and Bounds my
organization has grown it's about 500
plus people right now
5 300 plus people
unbelievable yeah the company has grown
tremendously and you know we continue to
do really well in the b2d uh B2B space
that we are in so it's an extremely
fostering organization and has been an
awesome ride for me personally too
and and a few bit about a bit about the
technological challenges or the
technological you know abilities that
you're that you're creating here what
are those like sure yeah so we uh serve
over 30 000 customers we have
Enterprises we have small and medium
businesses we have mid Market if it's a
wide variety of of uh the customer base
uh we have grown through acquisite
Acquisitions as well and as you can
imagine with each acquisition we spend
time in integrating the technology stack
right so as we have grown one of the
challenges that we have faced is how to
make sure the acquisition that comes in
is integrated with the technology can be
part of a common platform and it's for
the technology as well it goes into the
people and processes integration too
right so those are kind of the
challenges which we have been facing
with
um and going back to my earlier Fort
around uh you know how uh I find it
fascinating to kind of help a company
grow some being a small urbanization to
a much larger the processes and the text
fact that we were working on earlier is
not quite what we would want going
forward right so as we as we grow we are
spending a lot of effort and figuring
out ways by which we can have a quicker
time to Market uh we are we are
definitely conclusive of the fact that
as you become a larger organization
processes will creep in and we don't
want to be overloaded by that we want to
continue to be nimble and be able to
innovate at an extremely fast pace and a
technology stack has to has to evolve to
match that uh what does that mean it
means decomposing some of the moral
attack applications we might have right
we want microservices we investing
heavily in micro front desk architecture
so we want to empower our teams to be
able to deploy
um independent of uh you know a central
process and be able to do that with
extremely high quality
right right and so you're talking about
maintaining high quality best practices
standards how how are you able to
maintain your own ability to be with the
best standards in terms of not
necessarily obviously just like coding
languages and and and syntax but from an
architectural standpoint how how can you
in the position that you're at today
leading more than 500 how how are you
able to maintain this level of sort of
cutting-edge conceptual understanding of
everything that's happening here yeah
good question
um so uh I've released that if you can't
measure it it won't change right to
start by measuring engineering and that
becomes very difficult how we really
measure engineering right so we have a
few kpis and metrics which we which we
uh look at extremely carefully across
the board at Zoom info an example is uh
our mean time to restore service it's a
common industry-wide metric called nttr
right and that's focused on if any SEO
product Services go down in production
how quickly can you bounce back up world
class says that on an average overall
window of 30 days it should be 30
minutes or less so they definitely want
to maintain that bar right so so that
metric is one we have other metrics
around the change failure rates
um what that means is for every 100
changes you're deploying to production
how many of them you need to rework
because of a bug right and our bar for
that is we want that to be 15 or below
so a few minutes are really important to
me because it gives me a measure of
things around the quality of what we are
building out and we measure cycle time
as well right your lead time to Market
if a product manager comes to me and
says hey this is a new feature I want to
be able to estimate how quickly we can
go to market with that feature and for
that I need to know how my engineering
team is operating like what's the cycle
time so I have a set of metrics which we
monitor sadly regularly day by day it's
not week by week and we stay on top of
that to make sure that we're continuing
to deal level of values of the business
right now the other part of what he
asked is how do we stay abreast of the
fast changing burn in Tech right so for
that a lot of us women for engineers
attend conferences we are part of
several networks within different areas
in Israel and Boston in India and so on
uh we published regular engineering
blogs you can look it up on our website
so a lot of Engineers are encouraged to
write about the cool things that you're
doing go and talk in different events so
we stay connected with the industry as
well and we are part of different
engineering and product forums where we
can actively listen and contribute to so
that's another way by which we kind of
keep in touch with what's happening in
the industry
I'm gonna ask something that uh probably
a lot of people listening here would be
curious to hear a and and perhaps quite
a few people within your own
organizations as well
what is the person in your position
actually do in the day-to-day no a lot
of people we know what Engineers are
doing we know we know a lot of team
leaders are doing even director level
but a person leading 500 people I mean
you wake up in the morning you say you
work hard what are you actually do in
the day today
my son asked me this question about 10
years ago when he was like three or four
years and I told him I actually thought
about it and and I told them
I check email I attend meetings and
that's pretty much what I do that
doesn't sound very inspiring to a
five-year-old
so so the answer to your question is uh
I feel my most important job is to make
sure engineering is aligned with the
business we exist to help the business
grow we exist to help the business set
up the mission for the company right so
alignment is extremely important in my
room and this is a like you said the 500
organization globally distributed and
it's very easy to get misaligned and go
off on a tangent and build out something
which you think is important but may not
be the most important thing for the
organization so I actually obsess over
that I spent a lot of time reaching out
to my VPS my directors their managers
their teams through multiple
communication mechanisms to make sure
that your super aligned on what you're
doing right so this could be you know
in-person meetings it could be your
emails going out or announcements or
blogs or messages multiple ways by which
we achieve that alignment that is number
one that's really important right second
is I think uh from a from an
organization perspective investing in
people is also really important at this
level you need to make sure that you
have the right team to help the business
you need to hire as always the past 20
years the industry has always been in a
higher ends free and it's always worth
getting the right Talent right so
continuously being on the lookout for
right Talent investing in your own lead
they'll see how we can equip them to get
to the next level is really important
and third I would say I spend a lot of
time partnering with the business uh
brainstorming on new product ideas on
where the product should be two years
ahead three years ahead for a kind of
technical Trends we should be
anticipating brainstorming with the
Architects or what are the new things
that we know that we should adopt and
maybe a few things we should consciously
stay away from right so it's in those
buckets I would say about alignment
about uh you know about talent and about
making sure that the I'm working very
closely with the business
is it easy for you to know if you're
doing a good job or if you need to no I
mean because you know I have it when I
was an engineer I had my jira board and
I had a Sprint planning and I had to at
the end of each quarter come and say did
I meet the kpis that I said for myself
so now so I didn't then well then why
not uh how do you in your position
measure whether you've been a successful
leader at least to the expectations that
you've set for yourself and for the rest
of the leadership team
that's an awesome question thanks for
asking
um I think the one way to look at it is
it is easy but after the fact right I
will know when I have not done a good
job because the measures that I spoke
about earlier in terms of my quality
battery stability metrics will
immediately tell me that hey the product
is not stable or I have quality issues
right so that's after the fact that's
one my neck promoter score for the
products will dip right it's not a
product problem so the negative part of
whether I'm doing a good job is fairly
obvious but after the fact now what I
would want to get ahead of is what are
the input metrics which kind of
influence that right what can I do up
front to make sure those things don't
happen and that is all about the reviews
that we do the kind of testing that we
do the analysis that we do right so the
input Matrix is something I see I have
control over and the more I kind of
focus on that I know that it can
influence the output of whether that
part of my job is happening or not on
the people side again it becomes a
fairly difficult one to measure because
again it takes time your hiring Talent
you're investing in your talent how do
you lose their will be turning out to
the great leaders you want them to be it
takes time you will get to know for
perhaps never through through the kind
of processes they kick off or the
behavior that they that they display and
you want to give them feedback around
that right so that that is a way you can
influence that but again you know that's
another measure of success for me about
the canvas leaders that I get into the
organization and that I grow within the
organization as well uh so the short
answer is it's difficult but it's
definitely possible
I like that if you are looking today at
Engineers listening to this in a variety
of positions and they're thinking okay
what are some long-term things I need to
be cognizant of to continue advancing
and wherever I'm at and I want to be to
continue advancing in my career what
what would be something that you would
advise us to to consider as we want to
position ourselves as prominent leaders
in in an r d sort of a landscape
I would say uh firstly think of the
technical skills that you have as a
must-have that's a giver right I mean
nobody is going to say you should not
focus on technology and not be
conversion with the latest trends and so
on right so that is something like a
tablespace you have to have that uh the
next thing I would say is collaboration
it's really important as an engineer to
think beyond your immediate self and see
how you can influence the other
Engineers you're working with the
product managers they are working with
the designers you're working with the
customer support folks talks to the
sales people as well right to get a
sense of how they're selling your
product collaborate with them get their
input and that will help you develop a
better product rate and the third thing
I would say is also invest in mentoring
others right you are an engineer as you
grow up your your career you will work
with a lot of relatively Junior
Engineers be patient with it invest in
them give them tips on how they can also
become great Engineers like you right
and that way if you are one person you
can invest in creating 10 other people
write 10 other great Engineers who in
turn will create another 10 and that it
has a has a compound based asset that's
what I would I would advise honestly
part of I really want to thank you I I
really enjoyed uh listening and asking
questions and thank you for uh for being
here I know how busy you are thank you
for giving me the attention where you
have 500 people waiting for your
attention at the smoke so I appreciate
the time and the energy and the
obviously looking at the different
things you've done it's pretty clear how
intentional you are about being a good
leader and being a good manager and
always being
um at the Forefront both of Technology
but also on leadership style and and I
personally very much enjoyed this
conversation so thank you very very much
best of luck with your journey at Zoom
info and every Journey that you'll be on
I really appreciate you taking the time
thanks a lot to you as well Michael I
really enjoyed the conversation I really
appreciated your questions they're very
incisive thank you
thank you
[Music]